[Music]
well my background I'm a medical
epidemiologist I started off in surgery
but I felt the call of Epidemiology and
during the early 90s I had to run a
course teaching people epidemiology and
and we went down to the Johnson ear pub
just to give them a kind of interesting
thing and we found that the pub was
really rundown and then one was
bothering about it and we knew there was
this big heritage in the states so we
were bit embarrassed especially as we
had two guys who CDC who were lecturing
on our course and so he said well we
must have a Johnson in society and
that's how it started the Institute for
Healthcare Improvement or IHI was
founded by Don Berwick who you may
remember ran for governor he's kind of
the Guru of improvement and our mission
is to improve health and healthcare
around the world and to make care safer
and better for patients and for just
general people who have to live in a
community and we do this with a bedrock
of scientific quality improvement and
most people think quality improvement
you just go out and kind of do it but as
we've been discussing it all involves
scientific method you know prediction
testing confirming adjusting constantly
running cycles to prove or disprove that
your theory of causation how you get
from a change to a better outcome is
true
in a way the miasma theory was right in
that there are lots of factors right
your general health your well-being for
Haven brought in your morality I'm
afraid to know if you were immoral you
were gonna get cholera but but that
whole idea the holistic approach isn't
wrong as such but they missed out the
single course and people have also said
well how does Howard snow said
absolutely strong honest when even
William but who was a contemporary who
came up with the theory of water for
typhoid he also hedged his bets but snow
didn't and I think it's very much his
because he was a very logical man but
also you look at his life he starts off
as a young doctor in the minefield of
the north of England and the mines and
those days were disgusting you'd go down
underground there was no sanitation if
it rained
they'd flood they had no way to wash
their hands they had no toilets and he
observed this and commented on it and in
his 1849 said you know there must be
something going on so he was very close
to the German theory although he never
he was years ahead before people like
Robert Carr came up with the germ theory
but but he was close and so he was
saying it's something it's something to
do with them not washing their hands
that are ingesting it from the water
well first I think it's only fair to say
there's no William Farr society and you
may wonder why I would bring that up
Wilkes William Farr was wrong but he did
use statistics and one might say
epidemiology to come to the wrong
conclusion
what he did is you may know is to
calculate the occurrence of cholera
around London and especially around the
Thames by it's all of the elevation of
the land above the temps okay and he
showed a really strong correlation
between elevation and lower risk of
getting cholera because he believed that
my asthma's these noxious gases
you know come from human feces and
animal waste and all that kind of stuff
all these bad gases were causing cholera
and unfortunately his analysis didn't
account for all the other factors that
might have been important income level
what kind of house she lived in what
kind of water you got all he did was
have this theory about my Asmus from the
thames and it looks really good if you
look at that graph and his data it's
pretty compelling but it's wrong
there's been a lot of criticism in a way
of the way John Snow and some of the
others of his time have become an icon -
Ameilia
and people have said well why him I mean
he wasn't the only one doing maps he was
the only one who's beginning to look at
statistics but what was very interesting
about Jon Snow and I think the deductive
reasoning the fact that he was yes he
was a qualified doctor but he was very
much a scientist of a doctor
and he believed in measurement and he
was against the flow of the times and
there were other people who thought that
cholera might be waterborne
but it was only as part of a general
theory and people sometimes want to know
in a wended epidemiology start right we
didn't really call it an epidemiology -
well later in the century it's really a
20th century phenomenon as such they
wouldn't have thought of it like that at
all they understood epidemics because
they had some word in French but it
would it could be just one or two cases
maybe even one case it was a nasty
disease and but the idea of researching
those epidemics they would have called
like a study or snow often referred to
the great experiment right that needed
to be done to show that that water was
the cause
so in this vast outbreak of hundreds of
cases you said occurred he used basic
epidemiology and and we use the term
shoe-leather epidemiology to describe
what he did he got on his feet and
walked around and started asking where
are these illnesses occurring and he
began to plot them out on a map which is
sometimes called the ghost map or John
snows map so we could see patterns
epidemiologists essentially look for
patterns of disease and then make a
prediction or find an association
between hypothetical causes or origins
of the outbreak
when you read very short accounts of
this map or when you see it presented in
other documentaries or whatever you
often get the impression that that Jon
Snow is you know walking around Soho
with a clipboard and this map and
putting dots and making this histogram
as he walks around which is not true and
in fact the more scholarly accounts that
I've read make it sound like he made the
whole map after oh yeah well after this
was over yes that's right did he have a
map he was making in his head did he
have a sketch did he show his tables and
have a picture in his head or whatever
he was he was very good at drawing out
tables and there was something because
of his work malassezia he was very good
at working with compounds and drawing up
effects and things so he would have been
making lists of the deaths and would
have some people like the local doctors
and Henry whiteheads accurate collecting
the death data what's very interesting
his notebooks which he kept almost every
day of his life for the period that he
was investigating this is the time he
doesn't mean he doesn't it's too busy to
reality and what I think he was doing
was not using a map but he was
collecting addresses and so on and when
he was presenting the information to the
board of inquiry they set up an inquiry
immediately this was a very nasty
outbreak with it some important people
had died and additionally before and so
he he was presenting the information and
that's when he drew the map to convince
that the map that's on this slowly Jon
Snow's yeah very much so
he had if you like he'd got the data and
this was just another way of
demonstrating it it wasn't how he solved
the outbreak when I talk to my students
about this I always ask them so did Jon
Snow perform a case-control study which
is fundamental that be geology it's the
greatest tool for working up outbreaks
that we have in a case control study you
study the exposure of the cases in this
case to water
and the exposure of the controls people
who were not cases were not sick and
their exposure to water pumps and there
should be a difference John snow did not
look at controls he only looked at cases
people were sick and arrayed them on a
map and said these are closer to the
Broad Street water pump and here's some
exceptions to prove the rule so as the
father of Epidemiology the fundamental
tool for working up outbreaks was not
what he actually and the rest of London
not getting sick is not considered of
control well he didn't really talk about
it that way if you read his stuff it
wasn't he wasn't looking he had a vague
idea that there were these people who
weren't sick but it wasn't a discipline
way yeah Reverend Whitehead was it was
not known as the father Abedini ology he
was a local guy and he knew everybody
and so he was able to go around and ask
questions first he found more cases but
he also interviewed non cases and that
was more like a case control study so
maybe wherever in Whitehead ought to be
the father remedy how much yeah I mean
but John snows what he did was really
quite remarkable so it's at a particular
moment in time before microscopy is
fully evolving as a proper science
before the hygiene methods have really
got going and yet snow is 40 years ahead
of his time anyway it's tragic you
didn't live to see that and what would
have contributed masses I think it's an
interesting that you're talking about
how theories some based on empirical
observation some of them remarkably
astute coexist sit side by side with
nonsense yes and it's no different still
true today yes right I mean series and
and I'm not going to take sides but
creationism
homeopathic remedies I mean these are
wild to me while theories that exist
right alongside of modern medicine with
synthetic drugs that are targeted to
confirmations of proteins and all this
data we have about evolution and climate
change and so forth so I think it's a
natural we hold on to the kind of
mysterious the not easily explained
phenomenon and theories and at the same
time people will say well you know
there's this thing called science and we
can actually use it to predict
you